every day millions of Americans rely on
insulin to stay healthy but the average
cost of that drug has more than tripled
in this Century nearly all the supply
comes from just three companies and
consumers and the government have been
pushing them to make insulin much more
affordable now one of those drug makers
that's Eli Lilly says it does plan to
slash insulin prices by up to 70 percent
it's also expanding a program that caps
most patients cost at 35 dollars a month
that's great news Lilia Luciano reports
on the lives that are at stake here
nearly eight and a half million diabetic
Americans rely on insulin to control
their blood sugar levels and a 2021
study says the high cost has forced more
than a million of them to ration their
doses a calculus that could be deadly
the price of insulin directly resulted
to the loss of my child Nicole Smith
holds says her 26 year old son Alec was
one of those patients after he aged out
of her insurance he was asked to pay
thirteen hundred dollars a month without
insurance
Alec rationed the insulin he had left
he lasted about four and a half days
doing that he was taking Eli Lily's
Humalog which was 21 of vile when it hit
the market in 1996 but has since jumped
to more than 274 dollars now the company
is cutting the list price of most of its
Brands and capping the cost to patients
at 35 a month Eli Lilly CEO David Rex
how do you ensure patients that we're
not going to see the same rises in the
price of insulin in the future you know
we have enrolled out a guarantee but
what I'll say is over the last five
years we've Frozen list prices and cut
them this is a dramatic cut but the
trend is definitely down except for our
newest products you know we're
researching new insulins and many people
with diabetes would say they need better
ones Smith Holt calls it a victory of
advocacy but it comes too late for her
family I think if the price of insulin
in 2017 had been 35
Alec would still be alive today for CBS
mornings Lilia Luciano New York
we hope it stays 35 for other patients
for a good long time